help me understand as a son's fan who
has to root for Chris Paul
he said who has to root for Christmas no
I mean Chris Paul is one of the greatest
point guards of all time and I was
ecstatic when we got him but that being
said the last couple of years have been
like just the absolute biggest
disappointment of my life of my life all
forms of my life personal
relationship family the sons so they
went to the finals they went to the
finals we're up 2-0 to the Bucks gave
that back gave that back real quick and
then they lost to Dallas and then we
lost we got destroyed we got absolutely
embarrassed by the Mavericks shortly
after Alvarado gave us some work in that
first round Series against uh the
Pelicans but
give me like the Chris Paul thing
because I have friends that are close to
the sun's team and you played with them
we always hear about him and Blake
didn't necessarily get along like what
do you think it is about CP that seems
to be it he because he goes to teams and
they get good right away yeah I mean he
took that team uh the Thunder team that
OKC team that was crazy I think Chris is
a throwback point guard from a
standpoint and he's not going to tell
you what you want to hear he's going to
tell you what you need to hear and I
think sometimes his delivery is off but
what he's saying nine times out of ten
is right
it's a delivery thing his delivery but
again he's one of them like you know not
it wouldn't even be so much cussing it
would just be like he's talking Chris is
a talker you know what I mean so he's
always going to kind of tell he's a
quarterback I think he's always going to
kind of tell you what he wants what he
sees what's he needs like all that [ __ ]
um and me being you know I'm you know I
was always older than him but just from
a era where you can you know you could
yell at me I'll have to yell back at you
I will but you know I'm out here I'm
with you bro
and I just think the disconnect
sometimes with CP and younger players is
just his delivery because young players
have been kind of so coddled in this new
era where you know you say something
wrong just some of these [ __ ]
to get you fired oh it's we are in the
middle of this cancel culture [ __ ] yeah
so it's just like you know these younger
players have been given so much so fast
and I say they're not talented they've
just been given a lot fast so it's just
like when someone who's kind of a
throwback personality like is barking at
you some [ __ ] don't like it and
Blake Griffin wasn't a fan
yeah I just yeah I I just think yeah I
can't say they weren't I mean when we
were on we were on I think I think you
guys are one of the Prime examples of
like people forget the injuries that
happened in your guys's playoff runs
getting hurt like getting hurt there was
like just some timely injuries that were
just like again like it almost like the
basketball gods are like no you're the
Clippers go [ __ ] yourself that's crazy
so that I mean to me because there was
that year you guys beat the Spurs two
years yeah there's two there tell me
those two years where you know we were a
top two or three team in the NBA hands
down we just
couldn't get out of our own ways yeah
it's kind of crazy man yeah yeah shout
out to CP yeah
um still making it work